so starting a little bit late but it's
time to join
i'm joining what 33 minutes late
ish it's a blitz tyler arena i
didn't actually know this was happening
today
until like a couple hours ago
so um i'll play most of the tournament
hey we have silverback hq is first
um
okay high level blitz time i won't be
berserking
i'll just be it's three oh so no
increments
i'll be trying to play quickly
london opening time
um yeah this is already pleasant a4 c3
etc
just be happy how's it going i'm doing
well
yeah as people trickle in it might be
hard to say hi to everyone
but i appreciate the earlier rivers
b3 is pretty typical here
and my bishop can get to d3
this is a move
i'm keep developing
i think a5 is coming very soon
queen diet is forest or queen c6
i'll move back next paid more people
true beerus lemoons
yeah i'm i'm joining late because i
wasn't home when the tournament started
i was actually getting a new camera um
but this is a it's a three-hour title
arena
which uh yeah i think i probably prefer
the blitz title arenas over the bullet
more time to think
i'm managing time well this game
um e4 is a move
a few options here
like i'll put the african c1 leave the
tension
hey it's more people welcome everyone
thank you ratty the first sub of the
stream
um let's trade
wow so many people oh from different
locations too
yeah i know this is a more
more european friendly time than normal
my last stream was yesterday evening
my time okay let's play this move
yeah this is a very very pleasant
position rook c7 coming
etc etc
i want to play this move but then
rook c8 we trade
not sure if it works
changes knight c3 even this move
oh
wait that might not work takes takes
rook e8
oh i stick with queen here we go okay
yeah so if takes takes rookie 8 i think
i'd be in trouble there
or wait a minute between f7
it might actually be okay
oh it's kind of risky i'm going to go
for it
it looks like rookie 8 loses a yeah or
wins a bishop but then i have rook
c7 and then it's just mating or
winning a queen thank you
pucasmo and that note sounded sharp
you saw the tier one yeah welcome back
everyone
good to see so many people let's win a
pawn
okay so now it's just a matter of trying
to move quickly
monday five i take here
for everyone just joining this is uh lee
chest high arena i late joined
so threw myself into the tournament at
the very beginning of the stream
hey it's stockvis good day long time no
see
yeah it's been a while it's been a while
since i've streamed
at like a european friendly time
had a lot of traveling in recent weeks
back in st louis for only a few more
days
going to russia soon
okay let's take
yeah positions falling apart for black
and go after this pawn
make some luft and shout out to all the
the germans watching germans invented
the word luft
right or luft still don't know how to
say it
oh this isn't force mates but it's close
okay let's go starting things off with a
win
2 13 that was my first game
of two minutes or two hours and 22
minutes left
do i need queens uh depends on the
position
opponent um
okay i'm black gotta play at stafford
um stafford
maybe everyone's considering it
i guess not okay so we'll have a king's
pawn
sort of italian four knights type thing
i might go for the early h6 g4 g
or g5 g4 can be a fun plan for these
positions
yeah this is one of the ways to play
aggressively where i don't commit to
castling
some cases like castle queen side other
cases the king just chills
shabbat shalom eric oh shabbat shalom
yeah happy saturday afternoon
i played this move this
is playable i want to remove the knight
and then fork the
the minor pieces if takes takes and my
rook connects with the queen
so if takes takes takes i take back with
rook
that's probably close to equal because
knight takes two
um stick with pawn a lot of tension here
between this this and this
keeping a time advantage
there's a line uh takes takes takes
takes knight d5
oh but then i just take everything
him rosen
him oh like a pronoun
thank you jungie subbing for three
months
okay queen d3
i could take i don't want to spend too
much time here yeah let's just take
a slightly more pleasant i might castle
soon
rook gh should be thrown in at some
point
like maybe right now i feel like this is
the most non-committal move
because my rook might want to stay on
the a file i might want to bond cloud
oh i might want to take and knight d4
a positional chess so threatening the
the free thing
like c2 doesn't do much i'll play c6
restricting the knight
hmm castle queenside
if i want to maintain a piece on d4
all this pawn's a bit tender
okay the knight should really be on d4
so i'll get the rook here
here we go okay knight's coming to d4
put the king on the dark square
might play this move just poking around
threatening this
this pawn is also weak a lot of targets
in the position
rook a1 i fork this is also a fork
take with a rook
okay this is going very well
i kind of want to play this move
oh oh no my pawn
it takes upon his mate
um that's a better move
check it takes in
probably b5 that way i drive the rook
away from attacking the knight and i'll
take and when the pawn
oh i miss that okay let's take and take
and
howdy from a very new saint louis in and
also slcc member
oh hey welcome welcome to the chess
capital
who is that oh it's critical brad
can i take this let's take this
it seems like a lot of people are moving
to st louis as nice to see
i'm not defend i guess i can't defend
take with this
and go back still up a pawn
it takes work to convert though
okay this should be pretty
straightforward threading a fork
how i do this though
there we go so i control these squares
there we go
get ready for it get ready for it
there we go okay
i miss a fork i maybe missed a fork it's
okay got the job done
top 200 let's go so first two games
relatively clean
oh welcome chesweeb shout out to
chessweeb
at some point yeah there will be a st
louis chess meetup
probably after i'm back from russia
um sometime in august
i'll be back in st louis during uh like
the
big events syncfuel cup rap and blitz
do i want to play here playlist and
bishop f5
bishop e5 is like a newer trendy move
i've been playing as white
oh no did i
did i fall for my own thing
wow i really fall for
no wait
i can take good evening from summaries
i've shown bishop a6 but not in this
this position
i've never seen this before
um so there's takes can i have rook
wait no that's a cool idea queen a4
bishop basics
um i can castle here i think it's so
clear for white
i mean i'm down the pawn
but i have the bishop pair attacking b2
if b3 there's bishop d3
i'll have to look into this
that's a cool line i think i can get
away with taking
i have e2 for the rook of knight b3
uh there's a few options here actually
queen v6
and the rook is being very brave right
now
hello hello
okay threatening this now
be a nice little fork hello to master
welcome back and i wear shoes subbing
for 17 months
um i boiled water i forgot to pour
the water i'll make some uh
i have something other than tea today
oh the bishop controls e2
i guess there's rook c2
c3 is a target now
ah i'll make my thing later free pawn
actually where's my thing
okay i'm gonna make some uh lines main
oh tricky move so that's a threat
tempted to take on b3 oh this is a
threat too let's take on e5
and maybe this move
yeah i have uh this four sigmatic elixir
mix
supposed to help with focus
there's so many fun moves i want to play
okay let's triple up attack this
so i want to exploit this pin
this thing is supposed to help me focus
but it was distracting are the best
loose leaf tea shops in stl
i'm looking to explore i'm actually not
sure i haven't explored the tea shops in
st
louis there's one in chicago oh i have
my pond there's one in chicago i can
recommend
called todd and hollins
um i should make an effort to explore
the t of st louis okay i got the focus
so it's equal material now
i'm up upon
what is this
[Music]
up upon the down in time
oh it takes like meat
look at this move ah my queen please
take it or take my rook
that's a funny move hahaha i'm
threatening the rook so rook g1 i play
this move
no oh
let's take
seven seconds it's almost winning though
let's go let's go okay i want this
oh it took some fast moving i open this
so it's it's uh like powder form
okay people see here's my
my lion's mane elixir powder
um let's go back to tournament am i
undefeated
hey i've won three games in a row i've
only played three games with stream
it would be cool to get sponsored by
four sigmatic
this is not sponsored um
but oh let's play
london okay i have a knife
to mix my uh elixir
i know tim ferriss has done some deal
with four sigmatic
that's where i first heard of it
okay um let's play mainline
so bishop b5 is my move of choice
some more water okay black's falling
into a
a nice trap pawn is gone
knight d7 i'll play knight b3
okay
so life is good
yeah this is one of the main london
traps that higher level players will
fall into
i can just take
i'll have a better knight over
the bishop black probably wants to do
this and this
or this and this and this always have to
be careful
so i probably want to do this and maybe
this
but this is very very pleasant up upon
good pieces
playrook d1
hey karasu morgan welcome back
oh yeah knife f5 is coming maybe
actually
not next move but someday in the future
i've never actually played knife f5
while holding a knife
okay let's double up
t oh yeah that's
not quite what i'm drinking but
what defines tea
good afternoon eric good afternoon
okay let's not spend too much time
bearded will welcome back
t is like the ground up wait what free
pawn
i could also trade i could trade and
then knife f
oh
but free pawn but queen trade i don't
know
i gotta just take a free pawn
so now i'm up two pawns
i vote knife f5 it's too late now
but maybe i'm could happen later
oh there's a funny line oh no my knight
that wasn't really a trap even let's
play this move
ooh takes takes d4
okay not happening okay just gotta play
quick
everything's controlled defended
play h3 and make some luft
the queen will probably sit happily on
f3 the problem for black is the bishop
is forever
alone
as long as i blockade the pawn
i might want to play knife f4 or i might
just want to trade queens
hi eric how to write an academic essay i
need help
uh just google it
google should know best i miss knife f5
but the knight really belongs here to
target the pawn
so for cure
ready to take oh
ooh oh
wow box running this
that's so tricky
i have to be careful here i guess i have
f3
not the move i would want to play but it
blunts the bishop which is important
because there is some windmill
possibility for black
okay here i guess we're trading
okay i have my knife get ready oh never
mind
all i want to do is knife takes f5
bring the king and i guess
[Music]
um
okay i guess i i didn't play knight f5
that game
had my knife ready and everything okay
at least my elixir is made
so that's four wins in a row i did late
join so i guess
i kind of gambited some
time the first half hour of the
tournament
but we keep going i'm trying breaking oh
carlson's playing didn't even realize
carlson's playing
so i'll try and catch up to carlson i
guess
the goal is to play carlson
need revenge for the last time he beat
me
okay this is a fun line
it's similar to what we had earlier rise
black might play queen a4
but there's some differences
opponent is clearly not prepared and
knight g7 is one of the better moves
otherwise bishop d6 would run into
bishop a6
i think 95 here
all i know are plans from this point f5
oh man can knife what is a knife
oh it's where you you pronounce you
mispronounce knife and you pronounce the
k
also i'm realizing black's kind of
equalizing
[Music]
i guess we can trade everything
oh we can trade everything and i win a
pawn
because takes i take f6
okay not exactly what i wanted
i'll try and make do with this
this might be playable knight b3 and get
some outpost square
yeah we're getting a more positional
game now
c5 could be annoying that's also
annoying
i'll play c4 i'm dreaming of connect
four
but it's probably just connect three
at least this position is closed i can
maneuver my knight
e4 is probably a standard or f4 hey eric
hand waving thanks for all the excellent
content
i much enjoy whenever i'm able to catch
the stream live
thanks so much okay i have a plan of
never mind
black's playing very prophylactically
also thanks for that
job othello
yeah h5 probably should have been played
there
now well it's still
tricky this move now
knight's going to come into d6
i don't mind if takes because in rook h1
okay i like the position now
leaving the tension
could take
actually not sure what to do here maybe
king f2
over defend f5 hangs
rakiri fork
oh that was a bad move
it's still okay though
everything defended
hey knife five let's go okay
uh now let's try and win
cha oh i can check and win the pawn
and then come back to the fend a3
okay very nice knife e3 to finish things
off
it's only a butter knife i really only
used it to stir
for my elixir hey top almost top 90.
that's five in a row let's go keep up
the fantastic work
i'll try thanks for that mad two four
eight eights
okay i guess i'll be zurich
wow fast opening
i think opponents playing a little too
quickly there
bishop is regretting its life decisions
but it's still tricky um
let's just try and trade queens and then
trap the bishop later
because rook g1 could come
and white's gonna get comp yeah
it's still probably preferable for me
um maybe shouldn't have allowed that
hello hello
yes tricky position it's dangerous
it was a bad move
might be okay it might not be
yeah it's not a good position
really
ah
oh no my thing
[Music]
ah my position was good at some point
that game
what to do opponent was fast
two sentences thanks for the content man
thank you for the sub oh two cents
critic is back
making me forget about my my pains
okay still top hundred kind of
oh i can't try out about right now
um because i'm playing a title arena
but if you remind me after the
tournament there's a possibility
um yeah there's less than two hours left
okay no more berserking i'm gonna try
and have a smooth game
like a hedgehog
where i get this cup from this cup came
with my apartment
i was here when i moved in
that's one of these like espresso type
things
okay so this queen of three london line
is uh is fun
h4
i'm not scared of discoveries because
the bishop's not defended
bishop d3
okay just developing okay now the
bishop's defended
so probably i have e4 now e4 doesn't
work
d5 d5 is actually interesting
play queen h3
no need to explode the center too soon
thank you kangaroo and nando's
extending through august thanks so much
yeah this is pleasant i have full
development
a bit more center in space
the king is questionable
because black probably doesn't want to
castle king side
with my attack
so the king might stay in the center
okay let's see what black does about the
pawn
so idea e5 wow a lot of people subbing
christine wow a lot of people extending
their sub
christine subbing through december
and mexican llamas sobbing for six
months in advance thanks so much
really really appreciate the the
subscriber commitments
speaking of commitments i don't think i
want to commit to e5
maybe this move first
provoke h6 and move back and then
there's a target
also realizing i should consider an e4
would hang
play king b1 good day mr rosen
good day thank you panini loves you
okay so trying to stay stable
um let's defend the pawn
okay probably i do want to play e5 but
actually e5 looks nice because after
here takes takes bishop h7
and i'll win the g pawn and get some
attack and bishop still helps defend
from a distance
oh uh let's not play queen g7 it's taken
yeah this is winning
oh bishop g6 is coming
still takes some work then
but my yeah my attack is stronger
queen will come in and then the rook
two different maiden two threats
okay that was pretty smooth thank you
harry bum any plans to post more one to
two hour videos on youtube
maybe the stream will be a future one to
two hour
youtube video if i can keep going
this name gives me anxiety
i'm assuming they're they're just a fide
master
misleading me
oh um do i berserk
no i wanna i wanna catch up to carlson
and i have a zero percent record with
berserking
also this is a first staffer gambit
of the stream so far
maybe i should have berserked i don't
know
okay we're having a fun line i should
have berserked
would have been had fun to play this
line like i don't need to spend time
so this is the line where the king could
come to e4
king takes e4 it's so fun
so if here i'm down two miners but
white's king would be uh a bullseye
um as far as i remember this is a for
this is just a draw but uh i will try
and play for a win
yeah i actually need the time here to
think like how do i
make things trickier than
checking queen f6
oh
[Music]
okay let's play this and queen d5
and i'm down two pieces
i'm up on time
wow
thanks for the donation however that was
i need time here to think
um
bee b no
c4 is interesting
b6 might be playable actually
fancy
tick now
actually it might work no it's not even
mid thread
take the rook there's queen f3
turning a4 now
man what is this position
okay i'm just much much worse
i feel dirty doing this but what to do
um no
no ah
oh i maybe deserved it too what to do
ah so i have a zero percent
rate of when my opponent
beserks maybe that's my weakness
opponent played well to escape with the
king
also played quickly enough too
[Music]
oh where's my hand sanitizer i was like
a dirty loss kind of
i did this and it went the other
direction but
i got some oh i'm playing a strong
player now
who has been me many times in the past
try and play something solid
i'll admit that i don't play this too
often
c4 e4
knight g5
yeah this is some weird like dutch
position that
my opponent probably has more experience
in
but i'll try and make it work
this is not king's indian this is a
dutch it's a the double fiance variation
have this move
idea to chase the bishop off this
diagonal
queen c2
[Music]
it's going to get weird knight b4 queen
c3
knight d3 bishop a3 maybe it's okay
i was going to say earlier my idea is to
play this move
not sure how effective this is i might
not actually do much
have a nice day oh you too
how is mangu still undefeated
mongoose or magnus
someone should make a photoshop a
photoshop
of mongoose carlson
i still don't know where the mongoose is
i knew
at some point but then i forgot
okay actually don't mind the position
thank you little tex-mex
or among us carlson
wasn't this a meme at some point
it started with like angus carlson with
like cow beef or something
okay um let's focus the pawn is almost
hanging
i think i just want to play this move
and win the pawn
might even sack
yolo
yeah kind of yellowing looks interesting
though
pawn's tender
i'm probably not getting much from this
trading i mean this pawn is tender and
we'll probably trade bishop so the king
might be exposed
oh okay i'm
gonna need a miracle to not lose this
okay chad is coming this move
hitting the bishop maybe h4
soon it's not over
bishop doesn't have too many squares
um h4 i mean there's rook f2 queen
it's gonna move quick
[Music]
no
there we go here we go
check
there we go
no
let's go oh i won that i guess that
makes up for the
other game kind of i won because i have
a knight and there's some mating
possibility
where uh i'm not supposed to win but
it's declared a win more hand sanitizer
yeah
i've gone through i bought this like six
months ago
i've gone through some amount of it
okay
staff for gamba time
maybe maybe not dirty recip
oh thanks for the dirty resub i'm julian
berman
so there's this plan never mind
okay i'm using the same plan as that
previous game i played
early g4
which looks playable here
also thank you scruffles and thanks to
everyone else who maybe i didn't mention
who
subbed or cheered do appreciate the love
i also appreciate the pin i think 94
oh 99 top 100
it's rook g8 this is pleasant
because there's a lot of pieces
targeting the king side
plan might be this or even this
calculating this knight h4
neither 4 is now a threat
um
oh die blunder maybe not i miss this pin
thing but
maybe it's okay because there's this pin
thing
there's this fiancado thing too
a weird position
i don't know what my plan is
i'll be safe control d4
i have three center pawns guess we're
just trading
block out the bishop bong cloud
going for rook af8
is this move or this move
i'll reroute the knight to e6
this could get very sharp especially if
light goes for a move like this
actually f4 i just take it
okay now i want to play h4
i didn't calculate everything
but this looks good
am i meeting oh double checkmate almost
kind of
wait a minute
i'm struggling with calculating mates
i think it's mate it smells like mate
oh no my queen
so knight has to take and that was
double check and now rook g2
and that's meat
okay that was a nice sequence
something about that kind of confused me
but it's important
like when i take and promote it's double
check like this
very rare for a double check to occur
like this
okay that was nice thank you t gains
so 95th place i'm approaching my highest
blitz rating of all time i think
my highest blitz rating ever is 2639
and my current rating is 26.38
ooh okay
can you demonstrate an england gambit at
some point if possible
oh maybe but that might risk
my my sacred rating
we'll see i'll play it by ear
oh thanks for the bits psychedelic
gazelle
so i am slightly incentivized
okay this is a fun line um
i mean from my experience uh this attack
is usually quicker than this attack
but these positions do get sharp
so yeah generally the idea is to take
and play a3
and now back has to deal with this stuff
if knight h5 i never mind
i would take on h5 with rook
so e5 is a fine move
yeah what's uh what's the approach here
hmm
i don't want to take all my time
maybe take everything and play bishop
knight c3 bishop c4
try this
so leaving tension between the bishops
going for this
bishop e6 i have knight h3 i think
i do knight g5
tension remains this is relatively solid
even though there's a pawn on
not too scary yet
um
it takes 96 there's a lot of options
here
everything starts with taking the i mean
there's oh there's queen d6 actually
might be stronger idea being it takes i
entered inter meso bishop c4
and with material oh but my rook hangs
i may have blundered i'm not sure though
it's interesting
yeah i have to take the queen
there's some accidental compensation
to treat every blunder as a gambit
g5 is coming
it's almost mating that
oh there's alignment like this
confusing position let's play this first
preventing knight or rook d7
i do have some kind of a nice bind we'll
play this move next
even this move
a lot of pins here
the king should be on c1
turning rook h6 and takes never mind
i think the ending is winning past apon
here we go
okay that was nice oh that took work
i uh spent a lot of time in the the
middle game
trying to figure out what to do okay
this is nice
top 70 three in a row
um playing chebyrashka
let's play stafford gambit
okay stafford gambit time
it was first stafford accepted i think
of the stream
knight c3 what's a move
i'd see three i think queen f6
preventing bishop f4 targeting f2
there's some funny line i think it's a
bishop f3 queen e5 g3 knight h2
combined with h4
there's some variation where there's a
double p sack
i haven't looked at this in a while
though
hey new top reading i didn't even
realize
thanks for the reminder
queenie one let's go for this
now i'm pretty sure almost h4 might be
simpler
i really thought though that this is
winning
[Music]
dangerous to rely on memory i'm not sure
but
lines get tricky
[Music]
oh
three months until i get bored oh happy
pre-birth
okay threatening this now i mean it's a
fun position regardless
queen both bishops a rook
um i mean this looks very close to force
mate
even queen e6 and how does black how
does white defend
just looking for other options but i
guess there's e4
oh there's a funny line so here here
here here on passant
and then oh maybe bishop g2
[Music]
i'll throw in bishop g2 and then after
amp sonic queen e6
oh but then bishop e5 maybe i just
castle
threatening rook deformate
so what's the line so here here
oh that's not happening free pawn
oh interesting
um
i mean this looks completely winning
what's the best route
just queenside castle
so i i defend the bishop first so after
here
here here on passant here here and then
some kind of meat i guess
oh there's king d3 right away
i should have played bishop d2
ah my opponent didn't on croissant
does this move too and it should still
be winning
i am still down a piece
but it's still fun oh look at this move
bishop c5
oh no my bishop and then a5
very quiet prophylactic move delayed
half crab
threatening b6 mate completing the pawn
chain
i guess there's knight a4 here online oh
knight a4 queen d5 mate
so a5 might be made in two
oh that's a move that's a move wow
weight rook d5
that's such a funny line
what's going on
i have like a weird windmill
okay i'm mating on b4
oh what a game that's why i love the
stafford positions like this
rook is randomly on d1
the pieces don't make sense in the file
the final position look at how random
the pieces are
bishops randomly rook here king on c4
okay back to tournament okay top 60
highest blitz rating ever
okay playing hector lewis
go for london
so another one of these
so i had this earlier where i took a lot
of time
it was against a different opponent
oh this move order
i have to be careful now because b4 is
actually a threat and i don't have time
for this and this
i have time for this move
a move might actually work
95 worst case i take on f6
so calculations takes never mind three
months to my favorite chess player
hoping for many more happy three months
okay this is looking nice now thank you
the cooper man
and thank you luke go win vegas
i'm trying
i think i do play this if g5 i take and
play f4
oh my queen might get trapped but
there's this idea
that's tricky
it looks fun though i mean h7 is a clear
target
the queen's not trapped it's just stuck
there's no way back and attack it though
there's g4 here idea being i want to
play this and then discourage f5
oh there's this move
um i guess i should play f4 now
connect four let's go
it's a funny position
i like it because it might just be
winning
if here oh if here i i'll take out my
knife
and maneuver it to f5
it's so hard for black to defend the
square
okay knife f5
it's only a oh it's only a butter knife
though
king h8 is resourceful
um i guess i still do this
and then when a pawn or two or three
or four
okay it's still very pleasant um
control the file want to play this and
eventually win this pawn
my knight's attacked
i mean i can win another pawn too hello
eric keep up the good work can you say
hi to my cat bart
oh hello to your cat bart the flawed
hello to flawed mangoes cats
who's a good cat you're a good cat
bart okay
um can i take more pawns
can take more pawns black is going to
try and mate me
i'll defend
ooh i have this move
thankfully
it's almost kind of scary
gotta watch my time
there's a3 here
looks wrong but let's do it
that's a threat
the problem is there's not too many
squares a queen can go to
[Music]
i'm gonna lose a pawn probably oh
this will trade
okay
and down on time losing
something
i'm up two pawns but i might be losing
both of them back oh i'm losing an
exchange
ooh i didn't see that
let's defend from afar
you are legitimately one of the funniest
people on twitch
so many gems of humor in your streams i
love it
oh thank you
i gotta stay focused here
i'm losing but maybe surviving but maybe
not
who knows knights are tricky sometimes
lights can also be clumsy
no
hey i won on time what i went on time
let's go
oh the clutch pawn oh i feel kind of bad
but
also good more hand sanitizer
yeah thank you harry mum and flawed
mangoes
and oh amc short seller also
i didn't acknowledge earlier okay top 50
let's go
carlson having a confusing position
um trying to keep it up
still uh 70 minutes left
play one of these
i don't encounter knight c3 too often
as white is maybe going for a hippo
so i'm playing a crab setup
not sure how much i'm achieving but
we'll have a fight
yeah that's a good move
take
actually not sure what to do here
this makes sense to push in queen e6
expecting this
so this is i'm okay
ah the c5 is still a threat
um
really enjoy your video on the budapest
gambit
i have been using it with great success
thank you hey let's go
okay i'm undeveloping i spent so much
time there i just want to play c6 and
get a reverse french unfortunately white
um
always just winning a pawn
okay i'm down the pawn down on time
yeah white's opening just confused me
yeah thank you sacrificial king app3duck
it's my birthday and you are streaming
again hey let's ghost of known
oh happy birthday steven gray
everyone wish happy birthday to stephen
gray
okay i gotta i gotta focus here i'm
losing i'm losing more material
oh but i have bishop d3 hey i love your
videos i always watch you to fall asleep
have a nice stream oh have a nice sleep
mr seva
i have to save the bishop
whoa the stephen gray giving me a
birthday
it's like a reverse birthday gift thanks
for that
five gifted
i'll have to move the knight now in that
f6
the dream is to put a knight here
or here and then there
and down a minute
and castle i want to make the game sharp
my only chance
really uncomfortable here
this idea after the pawn
uh taking some risks
that's a good move
i'm in deep trouble
ah let's try this idea rook d3
doh there goes my hope
and dreams okay well played
ah i gotta play that game
okay let's do a chant happy birthday
yeah i started a chant so now people can
chant
okay oh let's not berserk
even though my record is like zero
percent against berserking people
hey that's a nice nice number of people
wishing happy birthday
thanks everyone
oh this is a very strong player too by
the way i don't know why i'm higher
rated than him
oh he's berserking a lot that's why
um this move is playable i think
yeah i had this similar position earlier
so now i'm threatening to
doesn't quite work though
c4 is a move
i think i'll just go for this takes
takes takes
i think i had this exact position
earlier i only played f6
i went for this line i'll just play what
i played earlier
i spent all my time thinking that other
game and now
i just get to use the same plans so idea
to control c5
but this was maybe like 10 or so games
ago
[Music]
okay so i'm gonna put the rook on c5 now
yeah basically i just want to grind
things down and drain my opponent's time
interesting
i think i mind the knight vs bishop end
game
move back to the center
there is rookie for rook c4 that's a
free
something
queens gambit accepted do you play e3 or
e4 and why
uh i play e3 because i don't know theory
but e4 is probably objectively
better but also more complicated
this is a move i mean there should be
multiple ways
from brazil play this first
hello from st louis
okay this move's coming
opponents fighting
there we go okay i feel kind of bad napa
is working but
i mean my weakness is like losing on
time
so it's better to save my time
and save my rating too okay
yeah e3 has like that famous trap where
you they try and defend the pawn and you
chop the rook
um i think g4 is probably more or e4 is
probably more common
in master play who is this
anonymous
okay playing a strong player
um i'll play this move kind of
transposing you
i had this position once in a tournament
game in chicago open
against the grand master i've managed to
win in some nice fashion
knight b4 this is a move
i think i should just take though
a6 and bishop here
[Music]
oh
bishop e5 first
thank you so wolfie and escrom
some deep words
so i might want to castle queenside and
then attack
the structure is kind of awkward for
black because there's
three islands of two pawns each
that's a move though
there's queen e4 here
no time to take
i want to play bishop d4
i mean we might end up trading stuff
ooh didn't see that move
pawns playing very aggressively
also thanks for subbing professor laxus
oh like prophylaxis
and jumery stopping for four months
okay things are still controlled i
probably want the castle king side
have a more positional game
question how black will develop the
bishop
oh next e3
really might have to play queen d2 here
yeah i can't allow knight c3
oh i'm losing f2 and g2
[Music]
ah there's my pawns
i'll play on because there's still hope
this move not quite working
okay let's play this and connect the
rooks
again have to treat my blunders as
sacrifices
i do have bishop e4
okay so i'm down two pawns
soon to be three
[Music]
i have more open files in black
yeah opponents playing like a
grandmaster
i want to play this move not quite on
time though
and these pawns could be falling
i'll play 96.
have to hope and pray
oh no oh there's a funny force mate here
here
here in mate that's not gonna happen
though
i wasn't even forced
die okay i tried to fight i was rough
i got outplayed what to do
give you a backer gifting to co
something something okay
jerk let's try and fight
um i'll play this
um so i have to move back
so i have the bishop here
this looks okay b5 and bishop b7 coming
and white might already be in like
really big trouble
it's still a fight of course
but there's a lot of pressure against g2
try and keep some pressure queen h7 is a
move
i can take twice and play
with queen h7 i can play f5 first
i don't know oh
okay can't complain with this
oh and the c pawn here we go
oh that's still winning
[Music]
foreign
okay let's go 52 minutes left
um top 50 maybe hey top 50.
okay so i had a
i did lose my streak from earlier but 39
tournament points
man carlson has 96.
um play chess i'm sticking with my same
repertoire
it's been working decently
yeah this is a more can be a more
positional line
more symmetrical line too
this is very symmetrical
okay break the symmetry a little bit
it's the thing like symmetrical
positions usually slightly favor white
so i can't complain
opponent deciding whether or not to copy
me
this is just a blunder because i take
here i think i um
[Music]
maybe i don't grab the bishop here
play f4
and then put the bishop here eventually
so we have a more stonewall setup
interesting
okay so usually i would want my lights
for a bishop in the structure
but what to do
rook f3 and just going through with the
typical attacking plans
bring all the pieces to the king side
probably knight of three
yeah if i take
i don't want the knight to come to e4
let's keep the position closed
go for this and etc
and put the rook here
oh
[Music]
and c3 can't be defended
okay let's control the b file try and
come around this way
it's crazy like black is rock solid kind
of
in this poem i guess c pawn could be a
[Music]
problem
okay perhaps knight of three
it's still interesting
i just want to keep pushing
push this way
i thought this just wins the pawn but i
guess it simplifies
oh my rook's stuck oh no ah
i realized too late
i'm just losing now
any hope
well played
okay i'm still fighting though because
this king is
looking tasty and the night's stuck
even though black's up by rook it's not
super simple to win anything
so soon
oh never mind yeah my position
okay i resigned ah well played
that was tough
it was probably okay before i lost a
rook
maybe should have been more careful
trading queens there
okay still hovering around top 50.
um what was my peak rating
it's like did i pass 2650
oh this is a very level opponent i
played this opponent many times before
opponents debating what to do
they're trying to refute the stafford
before the game starts let's scope it
oh they berser they they've used all
their time and then berserked
interesting
let's go thanks for that bombs 13.
okay
yeah i'm allowing this my light should
be on d4 here
i'll pull it on d5 go for this
hey thanks for the raid naomi
appreciate it you're just joining
i have to stay focused in the midst of
the
leeches titled arena
having a decent tournament so far
0.95
even knight g6 let's try knight g6
keeping d5 open for the rook potentially
i just blunder no
okay so hitting this pawn preparing this
my queen defends backwards
yeah this is looking very pleasant now
can trade and play this move
i'm not sure if i'm winning anything
though
yeah that didn't really accomplish much
i guess i just moved back or uh we
traded move back
[Music]
um
yeah i'm slightly worse here but i do
have the time advantage
very tricky
risky move
yeah getting outplayed
thanks for buying merch whoever just
bought merch
try this move
it's not so bad
oh maybe this is so bad
i missed a fork
no don't meet me
[Music]
oh that was rough yeah it's hard to
get stalemated there with the bishops of
office of colors
ah what to do thank you bass space
subbing at tier one
master of chess three
oh that was my first two losses in a row
of the tournament
it feels bad oh thank you like a leaf
your words make me feel less bad
okay um
let's try and rebound there's still 40
minutes left
still time to catch up to magnus maybe
uh queen f4 would be a novelty
i'll play this line in kopsky london
i have to remember how to play this
oh i supposed to check first
i messed this up a little bit but
is that a mouse slip take back
no that's probably a mouse slip
no way that was intended
i was hoping black would castle because
then i would be in in prep again
but i guess king f8 is uh
it's better for me
i guess take backs aren't allowed in
these sort of tournaments
so yeah like if the king was castled i
have knight g5
hmm
i might just have to take
just enjoy the fact i can castle
okay i spent a lot of time there
my position is very solid
b3
b3 might actually do stuff because b5 i
have a4
i didn't look at this too closely takes
maybe d5
so now i want to get to a point where
my black will take i take back and have
the h file
[Music]
get my queen active i can take this way
might just win a piece
and there's b3 here but then i take on
d7 with queen
b3 there i think it's okay
it's weird and black has comp
funny line rook t8 here here and then
triple fork
and knight d4 is definitely a move i
want to play
just to question how to
have the bishop escape
like queen e2 here
don't think queen h5 does much
oh g2 is hanging i'll play e4
there we go
yeah this should be pretty
straightforward when now
ooh fancy i mean there's king f6
it's fancy though
no draw
what to do
maybe this no what am i doing here this
move no
i'm just confusing myself i'll just take
i'm hoping to win quicker but
i guess that won't be the case
thoughts on arizona iced teas oh
i'm not a big fan of the
isn't there i might be confusing the
brand
but
yeah isn't there like artificial
sweetener or something
if it has high fructose corn syrup then
i'm not a fan but
if it if it's like uns if it's
like lightly sweet it depends
i feel like last time i had arizona iced
tea it was like years ago
wow what a move let's play this move
that was a fancy move
what is this okay that's a free thing a5
was so random
that was a cool move rookie one like
promotion tactics
no draw
i can explain like i didn't uh
just kind of flag i guess
um the reason why i don't take
is because after it takes takes b2 i
can't stop the pawn from promoting
because my king blocks the first rank
so that was tricky move
okay we move on top 60.
hey it's pam oh no pam's wi-fi
oh no don't leave maybe come back later
and hopefully the wi-fi will be better
oh i'm playing king's crusher i should
have played e4
because i know he likes to play stafford
as well
play one of these
i feel like we've had this position
before
charlotte king's rusher who's also i
assume streaming
also thank you to neon hawk
buying merch appreciate it
um okay i gotta focus
to do here king a1 maybe maybe listen
this idea
another idea to lunge the g
pawn
let's do it
ooh tricky move
take and play bishop h2
[Music]
or bishop g3 so there's a pin
and he's playing aggressively
to have this move attacking the knight
unleashing the rook
preparing g5
okay go after the pawn now so i have one
two three four
five against four okay
so a lot of attackers and a lot of
defenders
hopefully the math is correct
it's still tricky though
just move back
i guess that was just a trade
but now okay now i'm up upon hitting
this
mainly this
be really nice to get the queen to this
diagonal
because there's no knight f6 and bishop
just restricts the knight
hmm there's a funny line
um let's play this so threatening this
but also this
i'm still threading this and mate
so everything's attacked basically
this better work out
at the very least i'll win like a piece
or the exchange
or mate
there's rook c6 but then okay i take and
yeah things work out and they simplify
take the bishop
not getting back rank mated
this is a funny line knight f6 coming oh
no knight f6 doesn't work
okay the rook's defended but i am up a
piece here
and down a little bit of time
idea this this and mate
ooh tricky this move
this is coming
oh wait he tricked me ah okay i'm still
winning
oh king crusher is so tricky
all the box pawns are fixed on dark
squares
okay that was nice uh took work to win
that game
and he likes to put up resistance
okay yeah i'm still trying to catch up
to carlson but he's
keeps linking lengthening his lead and
his winning streak that's insane
and his rating is also insane
okay
playing at first i thought this had
killed yourself
but it's khalid yusuf
okay stop for gamba time
so i haven't played this opponent yet
but i've played actually haven't
encountered d4
played the more symmetrical positions
so going after this pawn
can't quite take because there's uh it
would be the pin
yeah bishop h4 i think i just played g5
uh rook b1 was preparing knight d5
confuse me for a moment
so f4 is probably coming
um this is actually interesting
so if g3 i just moved back and then f4 i
uh i trapped the rook
actually the rook yeah rook was about to
be trapped
just have to watch out for this move
but i am up the exchange now
i might want to take eventually just to
simplify
and there's queen g2
[Music]
not the prettiest move
okay now i can do this
that was the point like after takes
takes there's no knight c7
oh but there's that move but i have this
move
i should have seen this ahead of time i
think it's still okay
this takes takes
everything should work out
hey it's josh what's up josh happy
birthday anyone just joining
i'm uh yeah i'm playing the blitz title
arena
i joined a half hour late but um doing
decently overall
[Music]
had some fun games so far and 25 minutes
left
in the tournament
trying to convert this position without
any hiccups
rookie 5 coming
okay i'll be simple
opponent was following the rule never
resign when you have a knight
but now there's no more nights and no
more on poissant
okay that was nice
okay trying to break into top 50 won the
last three in a row
yeah a lot of title players playing over
500 players in this tournament
carlson is leading not dropping a single
game
oh but he's in trouble kind of right
oh he's in a lot of trouble he's about
to lose his first game
i think
i shouldn't watch too intently
but i assume he's losing
yeah he's dead wow he lost his first
game
that was the first game i watched of his
two
maybe i should watch more of his games
oh this is a fun line
this is uh yeah b5 is a key move in this
variation
it looks like upon sacrifice but the
point is i win the pawn right back
and then i i solved the problem of my
light squared bishop
just rook goes back i vaguely remember
engine says this is okay but don't want
to deal with bishop a5
okay so i think just bishop b7 here
enjoy the bishops
the rook might want to be here actually
the queen goes here have a pretty
stable development setup
ooh okay i probably have to trade
hmm
like rook b2
[Music]
alright let's uh let's develop first
okay so all these files are open
[Music]
relatively similar pawn structure
i really want to take but doesn't quite
work
just making luft
i still want to take but it doesn't work
oh i can try and remove the oh it
doesn't work either
okay let's play this
it's probably close to equal trying to
evaluate this
i feel like my bishop is slightly better
than white's bishop
and knight c5 here
gotta move quicker though
okay i'm just trading everything
getting low on time this looks very josh
but
game will go on
ooh okay so here i can
take and play knight f3
there's queen c7 in the end
then rook b7
hmm there could be
[Music]
two man
queen d5 let's play queen e5 keep things
simple
not sure if it works for like to trade
[Music]
queens
okay so my plan is to move the king here
chase work away from covering d5 and
then win a2
i'm happy with this decision because now
the position is just much easier to play
now i'm the one with the time advantage
too
oh yeah the structure is uh perfectly
symmetrical
but i have the better rook oh but
there's rook b5
ooh rook b5 is missed
oh
[Music]
should not have allowed that
this move
yeah the king's coming in
take
it gets kind of weird
[Music]
but weird in my favor
okay that was nice oh that was a gm too
from russia just curious who that was
yeah not not someone i've heard of
before
okay top uh top 50 top 50.
i think i'm at my peak rating almost
okay this is a fun line queen g4
okay so now this is the target
the queen's still tied down to the pawn
so
yeah c6 was probably the best let's go
thank you tw yeah this is just a very
pleasant position
because the pieces for black are kind of
sad
i probably want to accelerate um the
plan with e4
combined with rookie one so it takes
time for black to like untangle these
these things you magic harry
that's nice getting this uh bit of
opening prep
and thank you static eight i appreciate
all the subs
yeah wasting no time if a3 i play
oh there's queen b4
ooh queen b4 is actually annoying
i may have just gone wrong here
wow
[Music]
i have this move
it's really uncomfortable though
man what a plan from black
if i take maybe i should take first
if takes i think i play king d2 it looks
ugly but
idea being i don't want to allow queen
b4 with check
if it takes i get the file and if takes
there's
some might be five possibilities
ah but there's knight takes
so i take
yeah i'm probably worse here the game
will continue though
i'm going to lose a2
[Music]
oh there's a funny i'd take on b2
not quite i can play this move
because the bishop's kind of stuck i
think the only move is rook here or
bong cloud thank you a becker
oh thanks so much for the the words and
the bits
okay so i went back the pawn i'm still
down the pawn
but i have activity kind of
rook b5
oh black and legally castle
i'll play rook b5 anyway
and knight f6 is coming and black's
still tied down because the bishop's
glued to the pawn
and the bishop stuck my king is actually
kind of safe on d2
probably after knight f6 i'll play
knight e5 target f7 prepare f3
96 may be coming
i might be threatening this
i like the position and the time
situation
oh there's a funny line to play this
sack and then this
it almost kind of works let's start with
rook here
i just don't see the knockout blow
[Music]
also this pawn is hanging now
[Music]
it's a funny line though
wait let's do it
okay let's start with this and then the
thread is to take
good luck eric and now work h3 and it's
a party on the king's side
i don't think i need luck in this
position but thanks for the
wishes anyway james hs
okay that was nice nice little finish
that was a weird game like the opening
looked good and then i think i was in
trouble but then it was good again
okay 41st i think this is an all-time
high dating
i guess i could check let's go
yeah at my peak i guess this is what it
feels like to
be peaking oh thank you dave
rejay oh very strong player i've only
beat this player twice
very fast player too
i'm playing this line
yeah g4 is coming maybe
i have a queen b8
getting out of the pin kind of
controlling the square
preventing knight e5 b5
thank you chadan welcome back drawdown
um c6 is kind of hanging
let's do it anyway the takes i take and
f2 hangs
takes like when the queen
this looks solid
those pawns attacked
i guess i could um
just play this move
okay so we have a reverse french
structure
not too bad rxc8 is coming never mind
a c file is an issue
try this move maintaining tension these
pawns look tasty
this and this i have to play this first
oh no my pawn 9 f2
down a bit of time but position looks
fine subbing let's go
hey let's go thank you j-dub
yeah so plan is this okay now i'm
preparing b4
what's the best way to learn chess
[Music]
don't think there is a best way it
really depends on the individual
what's most important is you understand
your learning style you're self-aware
and you're passionate and you have a
growth mindset and pawn still defended
okay rick wants to be here
i'm just waiting around
i don't know what my plan is here this
move
and sneak in this way
oh white's being sneaky too
play this
oh now that fate's the threat wow i have
to take
ah my rook ah
it was very sneaky
i'm almost getting zugzwang
good technique
[Music]
last over the g5 h4
and i'm hoping that white can't stop my
passer which is maybe a possibility
weirdly enough it's crazy but this pawn
might pull a miracle
no ah it's so close wait am i
no i'm not in time i need one more move
uh
okay i resign ah that's so sad that was
almost a miracle
[Music]
is there any chance because i had to
prevent this
and then
yeah if i play this series rook g1
that was really close okay i almost set
up a trick
a game still top 50. there was my
five in a row win streak the opponent
was very sneaky with the the knight
invasion
okay this name also gives me anxiety
i don't know which name is worse
murderbot or the one i played earlier
the cheater bot
um okay we're gonna have a
one of these danish declined
so the key move here not this because
then oh no my queen but queen c4
and this is one of the reasons why this
line isn't so popular for white
oh this could be the last game too
at least the last game that counts for
the tournament
so i might have only one more chance to
play magnus
so the goal is to win quickly watch
magnus and then rejoin the tournament
when magnus finishes
very optimistic though
oh this is a funny line queen a4 b5
if takes i fork and if uh if my takes i
made on e2
meanwhile i'm just printing this
i guess that defends wow
i guess queen a6
the queen does its job here
so i probably want a queenside castle
soon maybe 9 6 with tempo
interesting
man i want to do things but things don't
quite work
there's a line where i suck at peace
now let's be civil
still preventing life from casting
yeah this is going to be the last game
i'll just try and win this game so it
counts for the tournament
which might be difficult
oh no okay bishop d3 have queen a5
otherwise oh no my queen
so i'm up a pawn
castle
have to keep this number bigger than
this number
i missed this move too focused on the
numbers please repeat
yes okay let's go
this is the one time that tr that uh
time traveling can exist
you repeat to go back in time
let's go okay ah pairings are closed
let's watch carlson oh carlson's paused
oh he lost two games and then he just
withdrew because he's
so far ahead okay that was a fun
tournament
top 50 out of over 500 people
i late joined half hour
what was it i joined when there were two
and a half hours
left it was a three hour tournament
oh new rating peak really almost new
rating peak
not quite though but a new peak today
um yeah i did cross 26.50 today
at one point
okay hey there's confetti
there's more confetti too wow so much
confetti